hi there steve here
uh i'm uh this is the
last day of my
visit with my wife carmen to
greece israel and jordan and so i just
want to talk a little bit
about kato lom's formula for effective
language learning catalog many of you
may know
uh was a hungarian polyglot who lived in
the night mostly
in the 19th century into the 20th
century who learned to speak many
languages
uh very much a believer she was of
input-based learning but her formula for
language learning success was very
simple and it's it's a formula that i
totally agree with and that is that
success in language learning is a
function of your interest
interest in terms of it's interesting or
interest in terms of you need it if you
have an interest in learning the
language because it might be beneficial
to you any kind of interest
plus
the
time invested
over or divided by inhibition that was
her formula i would change it a little
bit and i would say it's motivation
including interest plus time invested
over inhibition and any other
frustration resistance negativity
that you might have or that you might
encounter so on that basis if i look
back at my efforts to learn hebrew and
greek because initially i said
i will try to learn them both
and what ended up happening was that i i
found more i encountered more resistance
with hebrew because the writing system
was more difficult to learn
it's not just because it goes from right
to left because the letters are quite
unlike any that i've seen before uh the
letters can have different values there
are no vowels there's it was just more
difficult whereas
greek was easier and so there was less
resistance so i found myself having more
success with greek
as i had more success i was more
motivated i put more time into it
so that naturally i did better in greek
and i ended up spending almost all my
time on greek and very little time on
hebrew
and i think this is an important point
when people sometimes say can we learn
two languages at the same time
you know there are benefits to learning
two languages i think there is an
element of a variety of dealing with two
different situations that's good for the
brain in some sense but on the other
hand it is a distraction and so i found
that as far as my hebrew learning was
concerned the greek was a distraction so
i never really got into the hebrew
to the extent that i spent time on
hebrew it was a distraction from my
greek so really trying to learn two
languages at the same time i think
reduces the motivation obviously reduces
the amount of time you can spend on any
one language and it starts to create
additional resistance so
i use that as an example of why if
you're starting two languages from
scratch at the same time you may find it
difficult
however in so far as motivation is
concerned
obviously as i come to tel aviv while
most people not all mind you but most
people are able to answer questions in
english
there's so many situations around this
town where you need hebrew i need to be
able to read last night i arrived
from the south
and i had to park my car overnight well
none of the signs
were indicating you know parking lots
are they open all night etc they're all
in hebrew
you know i went to the first parking lot
and it was an open air parking lot and i
asked the fellow if i could park there
overnight he said yes a hundred shekels
my friend
i thought to myself thanks my friend but
that's a ridiculous price so then i
drove around finally parked underneath
the concert center here but again all
the explanations
are in hebrew
what does it cost per night i haven't a
clue but at any rate i'm here so i just
parked there and so you need
the language to function and i feel more
uncomfortable when i'm in a place where
i don't
not only speak the language but where i
can't
read
so if i come back to hebrew to israel
which i would like to do i'm gonna
definitely put that effort concentrated
effort into learning hebrew at least
enough to be able to read what's going
on before i come here
there you have it the next video that
you see
from me will be from canada and i just
wanted to stress this the sort of magic
formula for language learning is you
want to maximize your motivation and
interest
plus put as much time in as possible
those two things added up and then
divided by
any inhibitions resistance frustrations
negative feelings
that you may have towards learning
towards using the language towards the
language itself that's the formula
so think of that when you
decide on your language learning
strategy
thank you and next time we'll be from
canada bye for now
[Music]
you